lissa in your opinion why did this movie
about Peggy Guggenheim need to be made
now I've thought a lot about why this
movie should have been made and it's
really it's a story about a victorious
woman coming alive finding herself and
really finding a place in history and
being able to be there for the artists
and it was a story this this was a
historical figure who's very
misunderstood and I wanted to really
show who she was and and I hope that it
really that her role in art history and
her legacy is really firmly planted on
the ground after this why do you feel
she was misunderstood you know I think
that Peggy's misunderstood for many
reasons and probably she is the culprit
of all of this because she spoke so much
about her lover's she had this kind of
open way of approaching life which is
fantastic especially for that time in
the time in which she lived but all of
her accomplishments have always been
underplayed and they're her
accomplishments are so huge and you know
now that we can step back and look at
what she really did in life we you know
she's she implicated herself in a lot of
different countries in a lot of
different art movements and in a way
that no one else did I can't think of
another person and another historical
figure who has in the way that she did
and maybe we can figure it out these are
the two documentaries that you've me are
about very bold iconic women one in the
art world one in the fashion world do
you think that the film world is as
embracing of female filmmakers the the
question of female filmmakers and are
they embraced by by the world of
filmmaking
you know I'm clearly very attracted to
the story about a woman but for me it's
really the story about transformation
that I am I like I love the idea of a
character reinventing themselves and
becoming someone and you know I never
really and of course I've been asked
this question many times of you know is
there room for women I don't really
think of it like that I just think that
we're all human beings and we just need
to go out and do what we want to do
and you know it may not be the right
answer but I don't I feel that you know
these are this is a story about two
women who defied really any of the norms
of society they were both very much
ladies though in a traditional way but
they accomplished so much because they
had this inner drive and what is it more
important to me is to have an inner
drive and passion and so I'm not sure I
really answered the question but I don't
really feel that I'm held back in any
way that I'm a woman I feel like I have
any choice of any man in the in the
world and you said with your documentary
about Diana Vreeland that at that time
it was easier to be original and that
it's probably harder today I did say
that yes I heard it from another
interview and I agree with your
statement why do you feel it is harder
to be original today today it's
interesting because you talk about
originality and here I've done a film on
two different characters mrs. Vreeland
and Peggy Guggenheim and they had first
of all life was very different back then
and there was there's this they looked
at the world that the world was their
oyster they had any opportunity they
wanted to there was no norms of how a
woman should be your shouldn't be they
eat they just lived their life and there
was also something about the people who
surrounded them you know the 20th
century was so rich full of these
important historical from if it was
artists or different cultural figures
you know today there's something that
I'm not saying that we're short of those
kind of astounding figures but there's
just everything is influenced from the
past at this point and they were living
when everything was starting in a sense
and so they they were there with the
original roots mean they were there in
Paris in the 20s with Diaghilev with
Nijinsky with Cocteau with Man Ray and
today we draw on all of these iconic
figures
and and I struggle with the sense of you
know being original and and for me I
think originality is also about
approaching life and this kind of very
honest way and very down-to-earth way
and I think that today there's a lot of
coverage of you know there's not a lot
of even direct communication with human
beings anymore it's much more through
the internet or you know not even
telephones at this point it's just SMS
Azure and you know it's you should go
out to life and just grab it and be
present in it your decision to use
interview footage that had some
criticism of Peggy why choose to show
that about your subject I think that in
Peggy's hist history is so confused out
there and it is partially due to her and
I think that it's you know you you have
to show warts-and-all in a story like
this and you know she has you know there
are a lot of people who have criticized
her and you know invent and didn't quite
know if they should validate her role in
art history and I think that when you
have people and who knew her very well
in the perfect example is john
richardson who plays a very important
role in the film
he showed both sides of her and showed
both sides of her personality and and i
think that it was important for him to
delineate these emotional shortcomings
or the lack of beauty or the lack of
good taste and then also to balance that
out with you know well she was we know
when she showed at the Biennale in 1948
in Venice I mean it was really important
and it had a huge significant to a lot
of artists in Italy at the time but I
think you need to show both sides and
and in this case you know she wrote her
tell-all biography so she was the first
person to really let it all hang out did
you ever look at the footage of the film
and say maybe that's not commercial
enough maybe it's too avant-garde and I
need to strike this so in the in terms
of the this film was a I thought the
perfect piece to be able to showcase a
lot of archival footage and from
avant-garde films to footage of artists
to
some other footage of people you know
had really it son it's footage that has
never been seen before in motion motion
pictures and and I for not for am I
would have loved to have so much more
archival footage in that film because
for me there are not many movies where
you can really show the lives of these
artists and to show an artist working in
a studio you know we have Jaco making
and we had that on kuzey and Duchamp
kind of goofing around like playing with
each other in the studio Picasso with
his art dealer Kahnweiler Gertrude Stein
with Alice B toklas at their house in
the country with basket you know this is
this is very rare footage and I did not
want to compromise anything in the in
the film for that it was really
important to tell the story the question
is is that sometimes does it become too
pedantic that's the issue just that
because it's in when you have a film
that you have so much historical you
have so much historical information to
put into it does it just become too much
to see all of these references to you
know your and and almost too linear to
have if somebody's talking about the
Louvre boom you see a picture of the
Louvre and sometimes you just can't help
but show it and it's it's also and I
think that I feel that people were very
they really liked the footage up we used
which is nice to hear
two of your films have been about
reinvention
how much do you resonate with the topic
of reinventing oneself I think I read
something about you that I think I read
something about where you said you
started making films later in life you
seem wonderfully young to me but how
much do you resonate with the topic of
reinventing yourself at a certain age
it's clear that I must be very attracted
to this whole theme of reinvention
because it's something that I've done
with myself you know I've never I
started my I studied art history so I'm
very thankful that I'm finally been able
to use everything I studied in art
history in a film and but I started
working in fashion and but very and I I
loved it and my energy was right for it
for it but then I really wanted to work
on projects that I was very passionate
about
and I was able to do that young at a
very young age and so I have been always
reinventing myself I've just really
followed what's something that I've
fallen in love with and I've done it and
moviemaking really started as it was
accidental because I decided to do a
book on my marry to Alexander Freeland
who was Diana Vreeland grandson and I
decided to do a book on her because I
really didn't know I had only heard
about her and I knew about her but I
really wanted to get to know her and
then I decided to make a film and I
enjoyed the process and for me the
process of filmmaking is so much about
research and I really love that aspect
of research and sitting down and and
conducting interviews but it's it's more
of that academic side that I love so
much it's a little boring but well how
is that to take a book I know one of
which you wrote and the other one
forgive me I don't know the author's
name about Jackie Bogart well okay yes
so what's the process like to actually
take a book and turn it into a movie
well you know we didn't it so in the
case of Jackie Bogart well and the book
we optioned her book is Peggy the
wayward Guggenheim we optioned her book
will be did not when we optioned it we
didn't really take it verbatim in anyway
we just we optioned it to be able to use
the material and to use the tapes and we
did not follow the layout of her story
in the book we really just followed
Peggy Guggenheim life story and but you
know it's a very unusual situation with
Jackie because she opened up all of her
research to us which is it which is not
typical and she had access to over 200
people who have long been dead and and
it really changed it changed the
narrative the story also when we start
to use the tapes because the tapes
really make Peggy come alive in a very
different way and Jackie asked such
smart questions that had just pulled the
store we story forward and that was
really important to us but it is
certainly not the typical way people
will work with books at the option so we
were lucky